oh I know what you're thinking and
shushes just chit chit chit this is
exactly what I want to do with my life
okay this is exactly what I want to do
no no no no I haven't run out of ideas I
got plenty ideas in the backlog of
videos to make okay it's a long compiled
list of ideas and I'm saving them so
today so today we are we're gonna play
dating games dating games I know how
much you love them so much how much how
much oh oh well aren't you in luck is
the first one it's really good
okay so many of you guys have suggested
this this game it's called
let's see if I can record my screen how
do I record my screen on the phone
ok Google how do I record my screen my
horse friends the horse calling me so in
this game oh my god it's just doing it
you click and he gets I kind of want
some now and she's not talking about the
carrots am i right
[Music]
okay we're out of energy now did he just
poop one out okay so let's talk to him
do you like ranches
I do Oh excellent
yes oh what a relief that we both like
ranches
we're like a perfect match and let's
talk to him again what do you think of
carrots you know that self realization
of what the [ __ ] you're doing in your
life
it hits you harder than anything when
you see yourself in the black the black
mirror while playing a game I need loads
I want to die all we level up my god
your bond has grown stronger he sure did
eat a whole lot today he eats like a
horse oh my [ __ ] god
what is that
he's just keep going hey slow down there
buddy that's a good moon I'll remember
that one for meit's yeah hey hey I'm
sorry might say oh my [ __ ] god
my pants are wet now great thank you
[Music]
the thing is in the baby so great great
looking forward working with you ona oh
my god
what
why why I don't understand I'll never
play that game again stupid game okay
moving on to the next dating game I know
what you're thinking oh there was a good
video boots oh it ain't over yet baby we
got more we got I got dating games for
days now this is one that I've been
playing for a very long time I've sunk
in about 500 hours into this game it's
called you've been caught that's a lie
it's called it's called Emma cheating
Liam so emma loves Liam but she's dating
this other guy okay so we gotta love him
like this love him real [ __ ] hard oh
he's looking next one oh my god that is
not very subtle is it oh he's super
pissed why is she crying [ __ ] sorry
what is this game teaching kids hey what
are you guys making up for making out or
some [ __ ] poor guy
poor guy love is in the air everyone
love it's in the air I am loved oh my
god what that was it okay that was it
and he's crying in the back listen I
know you're lonely I know you don't have
a friend I'll I'll help you just follow
these games oh this one has a funky tune
I like I like this one a lot catch your
chance okay well how about we start with
the first date first date
excellent three two one catch your
chance what is happening am i
controlling this oh I am okay how okay I
iced smooth move oh look at this guy mr.
cool mr. smooth over here trying to get
around this
in the cinema all right we got the stars
now let's move in for the shoulder touch
oh my god [ __ ] yeah hell yeah now if I
was only a smooth as mrs. slippy over
here all right scratch that itch is the
next one okay all right this might be
difficult but I'll do my best
all right I wish his I am curious if his
other parts are the same like this I can
only imagine
[Music]
Oh am I actually supposed to oh my god
you lose well that's in the the eye of
the owner you know what I mean I am 27
years old you know she's pretty hot for
slippy so we gotta we gotta make sure we
do this right there we go thanks for
moving your feet honey Oh probably under
my feet as well okay got it
then what what's up how long is my arm
I'm gonna itch myself oh that's
brilliant this is how I do it too it's
it's a normal standard procedure here we
go don't [ __ ] this up oh all right
I actually own our own English myself
Jake Jesus Christ okay we have two more
levels we got any price mom that's fine
impress her mom well this should be easy
the music really helps with oh god she's
not impressed is she what is she Marge
Simpson oh that's a bird now let's
swoosh in baby
hi you're doin girl that's real smooth
that's real [ __ ] smooth I finally
played this game when I was a kid oh let
me tell you things would be different
tongue-tied what the [ __ ] is that tongue
time
[Music]
No oh my god
Oh her vagina better oh my god oh my god
I know I don't know about this this is
some weird hentai [ __ ] man Oh beautiful
I know what you're thinking
and I'm thinking the same thing on three
best [ __ ] Naruto
[Music]
[Applause]
oh all you think of Naruto I prefer not
to think of Naruto
okay Sakurai I'd swear that's [ __ ]
cry okay space to get closer oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god hahaha she
has herpes
time space to run
[Music]
I run with Ericka [ __ ] you you have
herpes [ __ ] up to jump why am I playing
this I don't know how to deal with this
you are dead for [ __ ] sake
I can't stop playing this [ __ ] game
well I think we learned a lot here today
and the lesson is to watch another video
over here to PI and leave a like and be
enjoyed thank you guys so much for
watching and I'll see you bros in there
good luck with your dating endeavors and
I'll see you in the next one as always
stay awesome bros you know let me just
take this time to say that I would date
you if you weren't so ugly